[MUSIC PLAYING]
My name is Pavol Magic.
I come from a
company called Sygic.
And I work there, as
a product manager.
Speedometer by Sygic is
one of our newest apps.
Our vision is to
keep commuters safe.
We started, last year, as
a team of five people--
myself, a product manager,
a testing specialist,
and three developers.
And we basically had no budget.
We just got some goals.
We needed to start the
app as soon as possible.
So we started developing
it in September, last year.
And the first app,
the Android version
was released in December.
So it was really fast.
It wasn't perfect.
So it was basically
a lean startup.
This helps us build
innovative products.
Because our core product
is Sygic GPS Navigation.
And it's basically 10 years
old, the same as the company.
So it's quite tricky
to bring innovations
in a product this old.
So you always have
to think of ways
how to create new
products, new projects.
And this was one of
the ways how to do it.
Because we have
three projects like
this going on in our company.
So Speedometer is one of them.